hey guys good to see you you all look
fantastic today and I actually feel
fantastic because I'm 100% completely
healed from my trip to the hospital
I have no lingering pain I've full
mobility there's no other complication
to it and I'm doing completely fine and
there's one more thing that I gotta say
before I start this video I just wanted
to thank lootcrate for sponsoring this
video because of them and I'm gonna talk
about charity later on this video I'm
gonna be able to donate five thousand
dollars to charity so there's a
sponsored video from loot crate and I'm
going to be able to donate five thousand
dollars to st. Jude's Children's
Hospital which I'm gonna talk about
later but first I just wanted to say
thank you guys again for the patience I
know this is the first vlog that I've
done since my trip out of the hospital
besides the one-minute videos and what's
crazy about those one-minute videos that
like blew my mind when I was looking at
him later people told me that those
videos made it to the front page of
YouTube like just my minute long oh I'm
in pain I'm not dying I'm totally okay
in the hospital hoarse voice they were
on the front page of YouTube and it was
amazing because I was reading the
comments the entire time that I was in
the hospital because I had nothing
better to do but sit in my hospital bed
and read comments but I was reading the
comments and it was amazing dilemma
because that particular video the first
one got more likes than anything I've
ever done in my career on YouTube like
over 300,000 likes and with similar
numbers for the other videos stupid it
was amazing to see the dilemma like do I
like this video because I want him to
get better do I not like it cuz he's in
the hospital what do I do but I mean it
was so great to see all the love that
poured out of the community because I I
know that I say it all the time that I'm
so proud of his community and I am I'm
so proud of what you guys have managed
to do and the support that you guys give
me in the causes that I do I'm gonna
talk about the cause that I'm gonna do
next
later on this video but it's just like
the fact that I was able to sit down and
have nothing else to do but read your
comments and read what you had to say
and see how much you cared about just a
doofy pantsless guy and I'm not wearing
parents right now my parents update was
false on Twitter the fact that you guys
take so much time out of your day to
watch my videos and I'm
saying it's a chore I really hope it's
not a chore to watch my videos but the
fact that you guys takes so much time to
watch my videos and enjoy them and tell
me how much you enjoy them how much they
impact your life and the fact that I was
just going through some pain in the
hospital and you guys were so worried
about Navy was touching in so many ways
so when I came back I was like I gotta
hit videos gung-ho 100% and I did and I
had a blast doing and I had more fun
than I've had in a long time making
videos and that's not to say that I've
had a horrible depressing time making
videos not like my life was oh I have to
make games for people to enjoy
no not make games play games but you get
the point no no I'm not saying my life
was like that at all but I've just been
having a blast doing different things
mostly just getting drunk and hopefully
I didn't worry people because it's weird
because I only got drunk two days out of
the entire two weeks since I've been on
the hospital and it's totally fine that
I did that considering I just got out of
the hospital doctor cleared it totally
fine I wasn't taking painkillers no
other medication I was fine
hah I hope I didn't worry anybody about
that but everyone saw like a new drunk
video came out every day so people were
like thinking those oh my god Marga bar
don't turn alcoholic you can't drink
every day that's bad and that is bad
don't do that but I wasn't doing that so
I hope I didn't worry anyone I was
having a lot of fun I was playing with
my friends again drunk minecraft came
back which is like one of the original
things like the first long-running
series I've ever had on my channel was
drunk minecraft and just around
with Bob and Wade was so much fun to do
again and I had a blast doing it but I
just wanted to say thank you guys so
much for all the amazing support since
I've got out of the hospital and while I
was in the hospital because it's amazing
to see like the channel is growing so
quickly like we blew press 7 million
we're already on the way to 8 million
and the fact that videos now they can
get upwards of 2 million views on a
regular basis it blows my mind because I
remember being back home was great for
me because I got to see my family and I
got to see my friends and I got to
remember like I was in the first room I
ever recorded in and I was like back in
Cincinnati I was back home
back in my league seeing my brother and
being among my family and it was great
because like it's been too long since I
moved out to LA like it's been so long
since I've been back home and really
been able to stay for a long period of
time and even though I was in the
hospital for doing and that was a reason
behind it it was still great to
experience because I got to be home and
I haven't been home in a long time and
just you know IIIi got perspective on it
because the fact that videos now could
get like 2 million and those those
update videos they got over five million
views they were like oh my god why
didn't that many people need to see me
in the hospital but they got like it's
so many people watching now and like I
try to put that in perspective like cuz
I remember being in that room and I
remember recording videos for an
audience of a few thousand and when like
when my videos started crossing like
each one started like a thousand people
are watching every one of my videos holy
crap I can't believe it and now it's
like a million oh my god it's
unbelievable because even when I hit
like a million subscribers I didn't have
that many people want not many eyes on
it I'm so honored that you guys love my
stupidity that I do the dumbness that I
put on the internet it's it's amazing
what you guys have allowed me to do and
the things that I've been able to do and
I just recorded a really really really
silly video with cyndago it involves why
I won't tell you too much but it's it
the title of it is sexy Marc or sexy
markiplier I don't know what is gonna be
just yet but basically I can't I can't
talk about it much at all because it's
gonna spoil the whole thing but it's
about me being sexy if you know what I
mean it was ridiculous and crazy what's
in it goes out here in LA now and I get
to make videos with them and that just
tickles me to death and it's just I've
been having such a good time but at the
same time I miss home you know I'd like
to strike a balance where I can still go
home see my family see my friends see
all the people that matter most to me
and be able to come out here and be
super creative
creative and do super great things with
my time here and you know I'll find that
balance I'll do that I'm not complaining
in any way I'm not complaining at all
love you guys have given me has allowed
me to do anything I want and I am
forever in debt to you guys for letting
me do that so don't worry about me I'll
find a balance I just wanted you guys to
know that I'm so grateful for the fact
that I have the opportunity to do these
things like you guys mean so much to me
and this community means so much to me
and I'll stop rambling because I have a
lot of information to get through
basically what I said at the beginning
of the video a loot crate did sponsor
this video and because of that I'm going
to roll this into the charity livestream
that I'm going to be talking about next
week next Saturday I believe it's the
25th it's going to be the next charity
livestream he got thrown for a loop
because of all the travels that I was
doing I meant to do this more recently
and actually next month I'm hoping I'm
hoping my good friend Tyler I'm flying
him out to come out here and I'm hoping
that Bob and Wade might be able to join
me and we might have a big giant
four-person charity livestream which
would be amazing and I would have so
much fun to do it still in the planning
stages so hopefully that'll be done but
that is the goal to get all all four of
us together and you guys haven't seen
much of Tyler but I actually did a chair
left with him with him back in
Cincinnati back home for who knows
actually the United Network for Organ
Sharing and we raised $8,000 for that I
think it was a fun time I played dead
space on hardcore it was very very
aggravating but a lot of fun so we like
loot crate's monitors video so I have
some things that I wanted to say about
loot crate and I wanted to do an
unboxing because I was part of the deal
here so this is loot crate's covert
themed I believe this is the covert
themed box and if you don't know about
loot crate it's a subscription thing
where you subscribe for a small fee
every month and they send you a box full
of goodies and you'll see that it's
pretty much worth it for I believe it's
IIIi don't know numbers off the top of
my head but it's like 1395 a month for a
box and plus shipping and handling and
that's every month and you get this in
goodies April crate is fantasy this
one's covert but
April's is fantasy and they change over
on the 19th of every month I'm calling
it off on the top of my head so if I
forget any of this
I should probably reference it because
it's pretty important they're helping me
do a good thing so I should probably
make sure that I do good for them but
either way there's a link in the
description below it's got a code that
you can save some money on it if you
want to sign up for a box I highly
recommend it because that racks is
really cool hey don't worry about me I'm
good with sharp objects I know my way
around a knife and that's not a
euphemism for anything but either way I
wanted to unbox it for you because
there's no cool stuff in here
so anyway Oh what is that like an
aperture science James Bond thing
there's a little dude on it this is this
is stirred oh I'm so sorry Mr Bond wait
maybe that's not Aperture Science at all
maybe that's just Dean oh it's cover it
is James Bond I thought the thing was
Aperture Science is portal oh I'm a
dumb-dumb I'm ruining everything so
that's one t-shirt in the box which
normally can cost upwards of 20 bucks
Oh oh it's a cool loop Rick is that a
bracelet is that a binder thingy it's
got a it's got a doohickey clip on it's
got a do dangle do dangle donger hope
the crackling sounds good for you it's a
clip II do I don't know if my big meaty
wrist will fit around this thing oh it
does there we go
oh I almost cut myself Howie okay wait
what is whoa what is this
it's a stealth rich watch wait how to
use displaying the time press the middle
bottom section on the Washington the
time will be displayed
oh that's cool is so cool it like
doesn't show anything until the light
comes on like I'm bad around toys I went
back home and I saw my friend Chris and
he used to work at this place called
coolest toys on earth and going into
that start was amazing just because it
had wall-to-wall of the most crazy adult
but not adult toys not like that not
like that but you know what I mean toys
ah forget it had cool toys it was not no
just no okay never mind that this is
cool I'm gonna shut up because I am
ruining everything right now
oh man it's a lanyard I think it's a
lanyard anyway it's got a clip for
lanyards on it and it's like a black
velvet one which also you can use if
you're a spy you can strangle someone
out now I should stop a perfect film
some sort of classified field notes O's
in notebook I love notebooks that sounds
so nerdy I'm not a nerd I used to be an
engineer you shut up
I actually really like I like little
notebooks because oh my god it's grid
paper
I love grid paper that sounded really
nerdy okay there's one with grid there's
one grid paper and there's one that's
college-ruled so hey you get two
notebooks that I like because they like
Lulu
alright I'm weird shut up it's like an
agents of shield thing I don't know what
is hard to open I actually haven't
watched agents of shield just mostly
just because I haven't watched TV in a
long time Oh besides YouTube like pretty
much the only things I watch are some
things on the internet and then the game
rooms that's pretty much all I ever want
oh oh is this a thing am i revealing
some secret code am i mind controlling
everybody in the whoa that is cool look
at this
I'm putting special effects in my videos
the production quality i markiplier had
really gone up over time except not
because that's stupid in said Oh Pat
knows what was in that I know Pam oh
it's for the lanyard oh don't make sense
oh oh it's for the okay
alright it's all coming together now I
get
I get it mad tubes mad lives
I haven't played mad lives in a long
time me and my brother used to do them
on car trips which was like two times in
our entire life but I guess they are
funny because we just wrote penis on
every one of them ha ha
penis oh this just in loot crate pulls
all sponsorship no money to charity some
dude dangles some flim-flam some feeble
flourish just information I don't think
that's part of the prize I think that's
actually just oh and a button I get a
button I've never been one for buttons I
mean a lot of people conventions they
collect button but that's not better Ben
for me it looks like holy crap is that a
magazine oh is that a comic oh this
comic holy crap there's a lot of stuff
in this one whoa there's Ohno that's the
bottom of the box also the box is like a
keyboard thing it's like a keyboard
thing so that's cool anyway that is the
loot crate unboxing I think I said
everything that I needed to say let me
let me double check hi I I was bad
enough of this unboxing I shouldn't ever
be I should I should never be called
upon to do another one again okay I
think I said everything the only other
thing is that the link that's down the
description it's this link here that I
it's right here you can click on that or
you can't click on that you can click in
the description and it'll take you to
the loot crate page where if you want to
subscribe to loot crate you get a box
full of goodies for a good price I mean
that was actually a lot of stuffing now
and there was a t-shirt like a
wristwatch a lanyard a comic a Mad Libs
and the notebooks which we're my
favorite thing oddly enough
I don't know why I'm a big nerd hey grid
paper it's hard to come by my little
squishy and he shall always be my
squicky mmm
okay so that leads into what we're doing
next week for our charity livestream
thanks to loot crate I will be donating
$5,000 in addition to what I will be
personally donating during the charity
livestream to st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital and if you don't know
about st. Jude's you can check out a
link in the description below to find
out more about it there's more to it
than I could explain here but just know
they are a great institution highly
reputable they help families and
children go through these horrible
illnesses such as cancer and other
various illnesses that affect children
and also they do research about these
illnesses and overall their goal is to
make sure that any patient that is
accepted to st. Jude's never has to
worry about paying the bill and only has
to worry about getting the treatment
required and that's a very good goal and
I want to make sure that they're helped
out in that just recently I know that
Scott Cawthon the creator of five nights
at freddys he donated a huge amount to
st. Jude's I believe 250,000 dollars to
st. Jude's for a livestream that another
youtuber was doing I can't remember the
name of the youtuber right now I
apologize trying to remember a lot of
information off the top my head but just
I hope you guys will be able to join me
there on the 25th next Saturday starting
at about 10 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
usually when it starts out so I hope
you'll be there and I'm sorry I haven't
been able to do it more often just with
all the travel that I've been doing and
all the things that I've been doing with
you know the the hosting of the awards
and packs and then going to the hospital
it threw a wrench in all my plans but
I'm back on track and I'm back in it I
just wanted to say thank you guys for
everything that you have done thank you
for joining me thank you for supporting
me and thank you for sending me all the
love while I myself was in a hospital
I love you guys very much I'm very happy
to be back in the swing of things I'm
very happy to be doing creative things
again and I'm very happy to show you
what's coming in the future thank you
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye